>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: OF RUBIO HAS BEEN
RAISING ALARM OVER THE STATE OF
FLORIDA IRREGULARITIES FOR QUITE
SOME TIME TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
I KNOW YOU ARE A SENATE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE STATE OF
FLORIDA, AND YOU ARE FROM
FLORIDA, BUT OBJECTIVELY AS YOU
CAN, WHAT IS THE CORE PROBLEM
WITH ELECTIONS IN FLORIDA?
>> THERE ISN'T.
65 OF 67 COUNTIES DID IT RIGHT.
MIAMI DANE COUNTY IS RIGHT ON
BORDER WITH BROWARD, THEY GOT
ALL THE VOTES AND ON TIME.
AND THEN THEY DID THE RECOUNT ON
TIME.
IT IS LARGELY FOCUSED ON TWO
COUNTIES, ONE IN PARTICULAR,
BROWARD COUNTY, WHERE YOU HAVE
AN ELECTION DIRECTOR, WHO IS
DONE THIS IN THE PAST.
WHEN SOMEONE -- A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF THE PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS, RIGHT, THE PEOPLE THAT
SHOW UP AND VOTE, YOU DON'T SHOW
UP IN THE SYSTEM, THEY LET YOU
VOTE, BUT THEY PUT YOUR VOTE IN
AN ENVELOPE, AND THEN ACTUALLY
VERIFY YOU.
SHE DECIDED TO TAKE 205 AND
COUNT THEM ON HER OWN WITHOUT
COMMITTING THEM THE RIGHT WAY TO
THE PROVISIONAL -- TO THE
CANVASSING BOARD.
WHEN THAT WAS DISCOVERED, SHE
SAID ALL RIGHT, I WILL GIVE IT
TO THE CANVASSING BOARD, BUT SHE
HAD ALREADY SEPARATED THE
BALLOTS FROM THE ENVELOPES.
THEY FOUND 20 TO BE INVALID, BUT
THERE IS NO WAY TO MATCH OF THE
BALLOTS TO THE ENVELOPE WHEN YOU
SEPARATE THEM, SO SHE SUBMITTED
205 VOTE TO THE STATE OUT OF
THAT BATCH, 20 OF THEM, AT LEAST
20 OF THEM, OR INVALID VOTES.
NOW SHE CLAIMS ARE NOT PART OF
THE COUNT, WHICH CONTRADICTS
WHAT HER LAWYER SAID A FEW DAYS
AGO.
WHEN SOMEONE THAT INCOMPETENT IS
SITTING ON THOUSANDS OF BALLOTS,
WE DON'T HOW MANY THERE ARE, SHE
IS NOT REGULARLY RECORDING THEM,
OF COURSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT, AND OF
COURSE WE ARE GOING TO BE
CONCERNED THAT THE REPORTING --
IT IS NOW TIME.
LAWYERS ARE ARGUING TO THE
STATE, TO THE JUDGE, TRYING TO
GET A FEDERAL JUDGE TO DO TWO
THINGS.
ONE, THROUGHOUT STATE LAW WHEN
IT COMES TO VOTER INTENT.
THEY ARE GOING TO DO A MANUAL
RECOUNT OF THE SENATE RACE FOR
ALL OF THE BALLOTS THAT EITHER
DIDN'T VOTE IN THE SENATE RACE
WERE DOUBLE VOTED.
AND THERE IS A VERY SPECIFIC LAW
FOR WHAT VOTER INTENT IS.
IF YOU CIRCLE RICK SCOTT OR BILL
NELSON, THAT IS FINE, BUT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE DONE IT THROUGHOUT
THE BALLOT.
THE MACHINE WON'T READ IT.
THEY WANT TO THROUGHOUT THAT
STANDARD AND JUST LET IT BE -- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU CHANGE THE
STANDARD AFTER THE VOTERS?
>> THAT'S MY CONCERN.
YOU SAY THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH
THE LAWSUIT, THE LEGISLATOR IS
THERE.
BUT HAVE A JUDGE COMING AND I
AND ALSO FLORIDA LAW AFTER THE
ELECTION, WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE
THE RULES, IN HOPES OF
INFLUENCING THE OUTCOME, THAT,
TO ME, IS STEALING THE ELECTION.
THEY ALSO WANT TO FORCE THEM TO
COUNT EVERY MAIL BALLOT, EVEN
THE ONE ON WHICH THE SIGNATURE
DIDN'T MATCH THE SIGNATURE ON
FILE FOR THE VOTER.
THESE ARE THE TWO FUNDAMENTAL
ARGUMENTS.
>> Tucker: THAT IS THE
REQUIREMENT, THAT THE SIGNATURE
HAS TO MATCH.
THAT IS THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENT, HOW CAN THEY ARGUE
IT IS NO LONGER THE REQUIREMENT?
>> THEY SAY IS ARBITRARY
STANDARD.
>> Tucker: BUT THAT WAS THE
STANDARD ON ELECTION DAY?
>> CORRECT.
THAT I'M HOPING A
REASONABLE JUDGE WILL ARGUE,
THAT IS A GOOD POINT, HE SHOULD
HAVE ERASED A MIKE RASOR
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE
RULES OF THE ELECTION AFTER THE
ELECTION TO INFLUENCE THE
OUTCOME, BECAUSE IF YOU DO, THAT
IS STEALING AN ELECTION PAIRED
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
SO, I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
QUESTION OF NATIONALISM PAIRED
THE PRESIDENT DESCRIBED HIMSELF
AS A NATIONALIST, RECENTLY, TALK
BY THE LEADER OF FRANCE FOR
DOING THAT, HE RECENTLY
PUBLISHED A
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" OP-ED
DEFENDING THE IDEA OF
NATIONALISM.
WHY IS NATIONALISM A NECESSARY
CONCEPT IN MODERN AMERICA?
>> AMERICAN NATIONALISM.
WHAT IS OUR IDENTITY?
IF NOT A COMMON RACE, ETHNICITY,
AMERICA IS A DE FACTO REJECTION
OF THAT.
IT IS FUNDAMENTAL HE PROMISED ON
THIS NOTION, WE ARE ALL CHILDREN
OF GOD, WE ARE ALL BORN -- ALL
CREATED EQUAL BY OUR CREATOR,
AND GIVEN EQUAL RIGHTS, LIFE,
LIBERTY, AND PURSUING HAPPINESS.
IT IS DEEPLY ROOTED IN MORALS
AND VALUES.
IN FACT, AND EXPLAIN EVERYTHING
THIS NATION HAS DONE,
INTERNATIONALLY AND
DOMESTICALLY.
WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF THAT
IDENTITY.
WE SHOULD DEFEND THAT.
AT NUMBER TWO, I THINK MOST OF
THE VIEWERS WATCHING THIS
PROGRAM WOULD BE SHOCKED TO THIK
THAT MY JOB IS TO REPRESENT
BELGIUM, OR MY JOB IS TO
REPRESENT -- I HAVE NOTHING
AGAINST BELGIUM.
I ALWAYS PICK ON BELGIUM OR
LUXEMBOURG, THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN I NEED TO BE
HOSTILE TOWARD THEM.
IT MAY BE IN OUR NATIONAL
INTEREST TO WORK WITH THEM.
I THINK NATO IS IN OUR NATIONAL
INTEREST.
I THINK A LOT OF OUR ALLIANCES
ARE BUILT ON THAT.
IN FACT, OUR NATIONAL IDENTITY
AS A NATION THAT BELIEVES IN
EQUALITY OF ALL PEOPLE, IT IS
WHAT IS CAUSED TO DEFEND
DEMOCRACY ALL OVER THE WORLD.
WE SHOULD BE PROUD OF THAT.
BUT AS A GOVERNMENT LEADER, MY
FUNDAMENTAL OBLIGATION FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS TO WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ON MOST OF THE TIME, IF NOT ALL
OF THE TIME, WE CAN DO THAT
WITHOUT HURTING OTHER PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: IT IS HARD TO KNOW
THE ARGUMENT AGAINST WHAT YOU
JUST SAID MIGHT BE.
WHY WOULD PEOPLE OF JACK --
SINCERELY, IT IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE OBJECTIONS
ARE.
>> THEY ASCRIBE TO NATIONALISM,
SORT OF THE NATIONALISM OF THE,
OR SOMEBODY ELSE.
THAT IS ETHNIC, RACIAL
NATIONALISM.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT ETHNIC
NATIONALISM COME ON TALKING A
NATIONAL IDENTITY THAT ACTUALLY
IS COMPLETELY RELEVANT TO YOUR
ETHNICITY.
IN FACT, YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
BE BORN HERE, YOU COME HERE
LEGALLY, YOU CAN BE A U.S.
CITIZEN.
ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT
AMERICA.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO LOVE
AMERICA THE MOST ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE AMERICANS BY CHOICE BEER
THEY KNOW WHAT LIFE IS LIKE
ANOTHER COUNTRY THERE THERE IS
ANOTHER SCHOOL OF THOUGHT THAT
NO, WE ARE CITIZENS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
AND WE HAVE OBLIGATIONS TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
WHICH, I WOULD AGREE, WITHIN THE
CONFINES OF OUR NATIONAL
INTERESTS.
IN FACT, I'VE ALWAYS ARGUED THAT
THE BEST THING FOR THE WORLD IS
A STRONG AND PROSPEROUS AMERICA,
BECAUSE OUR VALUES INFUSE OUR
DECISION-MAKING.
AND SO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO.
SO THERE ARE PEOPLE -- I THINK
THAT IS WHAT MACRON IS ARGUING.
THAT FRANCE'S OBLIGATION COME
UNDER HIM, ANYWAYS, NOT JUST TO
THE FRENCH PEOPLE, BUT TO    TOT
THE FRENCH PEOPLE, BUT TO    TOE
AMORPHOUS INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
WHICH I'M NOT AGAINST, I DEFEND
THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION, SO
LONG AS THEY ARE IN THE NATIONAL
INTEREST OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE THAT IS THE
COUNTRY REPRESENT.
>> YEAH.
I SWORE MY ALLEGIANCE, THE OATH,
I SWORE AN OATH TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I WORK FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND I BELIEVE I CAN DO SO WHILE
STILL BEING STRONG ALLIES OF
JAPAN, STRONG ALLIES OF
GREAT BRITAIN, STRONG ALLIES OF
COUNTRIES ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
ESPECIALLY WHEN OUR INTERESTS
INTERSECT.
>> Tucker: I THINK THIS IS A
VITAL CONVERSATION, AND I'M GLAD